[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
bonsoir bonsoir écrit ma cinquième
saison 2 la saison 2 la maturité du gel
hydroalcoolique on va en mettre à mal
dans la journée salut à toi jeune
entrepreneur est ce que tu préfères
faire pitié prendre le bus tous les
jours joe kembs avec moi et peut-être
pouvoir acquérir ce genre de tableaux de
gamme
moi je pense que la question allait vite
répondu un jour qu'elle va nous falloir
deux équipes les candidats les deux
équipes aujourd'hui nous avons monsieur
jamel debbouze
[Applaudissements]
voir qu'il préférait tu as bien démarrer
un monsieur de booth sera associé à
monsieur eric judor
[Applaudissements]
c'est sûr on a fait h ensemble
si tu te dis pas mais monsieur alban
ivanov
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ou qu'il irait jusqu'au bout dickens
nous avons quatre joueurs et deux
équipes
je vous distribue les cartes j'en ai
talent 4 milieu de la table et à mon top
vous devez échanger vos cartes avec
celles disposées sur le tapis de jeu
dans le but de réunir 4 cartes
identiques et de le faire savoir à votre
coéquipier sans vous faire choper par
les adversaires
comment le faire savoir à votre équipier
en lui faisant le signe secret sur
lequel vous serez mis d'accord ce
dernier cri alors keynes et l'équipe
marque un point mais attention si le
joueur adverse pensent avoir découvert
votre routine secret ils sûrs contre
calais si c'est vrai c'est lui qui
marque un point et le jeu reprend le
match se joue en trois parties mais qui
marquant le plus de points accède à la
grande finale
la grève c'est bon mais vous n'avez pas
ces règles c'est pour que les gens
comprennent ne vous inquiétez pas vous
c'est moi le patron du super peps accord
déjà contre 4 cm contre 28,1 contre ken
chan première partie c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon
il va falloir donner des signes on voit
tout de suite que vous avez choisi juste
avant pour les gens qui sont chez eux
qu'ils ne comprennent pas moi c'est un
signe physique arrive vers toi fais une
table entre ses sentiments possibles à
90 pas vu mais n'y a pas de mains c'est
pas possible c'est vraiment un si besoin
par ailleurs moi c'est sonore je dirais
faut pas que ramzi transpire beaucoup
nous avons le premier signe pour la
première manche tu trouves pas que ramzi
transpire beaucoup
si donc on a trois chart thaï way est un
cli de loups ah oui ça veut dire que on
en a que 3 ça veut pas dire qu'elles
n'ont rien montré le thème ses rêves
asie et riche
ce serait mieux si une première manche
asie très choix serait vas-y ils
trichent et bourgeois car il faut donc
le quart des cartes que j'ai pu et on va
pas jouer les quatre rois dames valets
d'amran les cartes avec lesquels nous
allons jouer nous allons jouer avec les
chanteurs qu'on devrait fusionner pour
voir ce que ça donnerait musicalement la
1ère cat rigolote que vous allez avoir
pour jouer avec ça va être
frank michael jackson qui chante toutes
les femmes sont bad à michel delpech
mode
oui j'aime bien ça avec enjoy the loir
et cher celle là elle passe par rolling
stone et charden
moi j'aime pas moi sinon t'as des fans
de 2020 non non non alors gbagbo en
valeur
vous applaudissez ça ne s'est pas saisie
sinon ça moi j'admire elle matthieu
chedid à outrance
nous allons jouer avec mes amis mais
cette fois c'est une catégorie mystère
je vais vous montrer ses cartes il y
aura un premier point à prendre la
bastille carc quel est le point commun
on est prêt à l'est avec un fléau pour
l'instant on peut pas dire parce qu'il
ya qu'une car à café la raison est les
jupes enchaîne charabia a bien vite à
bougie algèbre qu'est réellement sont
tous chauds non le confinement non non
pardon pardon pardon il a rappelé que
sont tous des mots arabes
un poids pour l'équipe de jamel debbouze
à l'étude
le café tu viens tu as roi la jupe je
bats je bats le charabia d'al arabya la
lolita merlini d'argile béjaïa bouge à
béjaïa alger bras jobs c'est nous si
vous faites ça mais c'est le quelqu'un
première partie y en aura trois mais
jamie 3 parlant non non je dis si
musique quatre quarts temps dans le
milieu si siri que je pense pas vous le
dire les siens al shabab c'est très
bizarre
nous avons aussi goûter pour maintenant
bon désolé mais parce qu'on a été trop
vite ce match très bizarre je vous
accorde pas à commencer
quelle cata temps d'aider que jeudi kent
state battant allez c'est parti
cette partie ok dubaï a joué à rien tu
trouves pas le titre en ce retrait va
être content heureux quelque 14 tonnes
et le sud je fume d'eric et de jamel
c'était tu trouves pas qui transpire
beaucoup ramzy et il l'a dit il l'a
grillé et il a eu raison il là j'ai nagé
qui se fier
je rappelle qu'un contre quand même je
cède 2 points
écoutez le score ce qui nous faire au
score pour la lgv en exil ou le point
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'année dernière quand on a fait cette
émission les souvenirs et les
téléspectateurs nous ont écrit pour nous
dire on ne parle pas assez on est
candidat est ce qu'il est possible de
poser des questions c'est super g d'eau
qu'un questionnaire afin de mieux vous
connaître les téléspectateurs en meurent
d'envié vachement bien on va commencer
par jamel et eric je vous posais des
questions très rapidement 45 secondes
ensuite je poserai d'autres questions à
nos deux autres candidats ceux qui ont
le plus de bonne réponse gagneront un
point est-ce que vous êtes prêts là
c'est que qui vont c'est que deux jours
et prend même temps et sonnant chacun
votre tour d'offres losc commence à
battre jamais les la famille traite avec
toi qu'est ce que tu deviens en tant que
producteur tu la trouves comment
l'émission pas mal dit donc c'est pour
cor le grand retour des réclames 6,8 tu
fais quoi toi en ce moment à y aller
tous et toi tu prépares quoi on te
demande un truc étonnant que tu n'as
jamais dit jamel c'était beaucoup
travaillé avec moi il est comment
ramener un peu sympa d'être y tenir
quand on parle de toi moi comme si c'est
quoi ton adresse
c'est à dire combien de temps h déjà
exactement t'attends tu as quoi comme
voiture en solo une crème au numéro 19
c'est mieux mais c'est un jeu c'est un
gars de passer une bonne réponse
le monde des vraies réponses
en vo et aux jets pas 10 06 17 17 3
[Applaudissements]
quand prochain à marrakech du rire au
mois de juin prochain est ce que tu
aimes bien chez diamal sanguines ont
préféré entre eric et ramzy éricain
tomates bien sûr combien bonnes réponses
là tu triches parce qu'on n'a jamais
atteint ce score 17 bonnes réponses on
essaie d'être comme voulait maintenant
on passe à la deuxième partie de ce
qu'elle peut pas rester à la maison
fonctionnement et des gens qu'il s'était
pour l'attaqué lui c'est
individuellement par cette deuxième
partie on a aussi convenu d'un signe
secret que vous êtes convenu et les
vêtements et que vous avez fait avant et
que les gens vont voir pour qu'il
comprenne émission même s'ils
comprennent absolument rien au jeu
deuxième signe
on n'a pas réfléchi aux deux parce que
déjà celui là là où sévit la semaine
dernière commence à distiller un mot un
mot il faut vous cassiez chloro qui font
ça vous va comme deuxième single leur
deuxième ci sera chloroquine il
transpire beaucoup c'est imparable comme
hercule cdja le signe de la première ça
c'est pour la deuxième partie met donc
on cherche on s'en charger partie à la
bei transport beaucoup quoi encore
non
gonflé le deuxième parc pourrait dégager
les chanteurs fusionner et on va les
remplacer avec la vie de rêve très
naturelle des miss france sur instagram
c'est juste des cartes hilarante
on va jouer avec ces mots jugés on va
jouer avec valérie bègue
on peut voir valérie bègue qu'applaudi à
son balcon ça c'est sûr valérie bègue
qui fait des bisous en haut d'un phare
et valérie bègue qui boit du vin à walt
dans les vignes on aura aussi la carte
marine l'heure ce lundi faisant 13 avec
marine l'orphelin qui sort de l'eau pas
mouillé mari de l'orphelin qui aime son
mec devant un manège et marine
l'orphelin qui est à la plage en europe
talon qui est sexy et super ensuite on à
camille serme hisseront 2015 camille
c'est ce qui marche sur une église
camille serre qui pensent et camille
serre qui nous présente chez floutés à
charge ensuite aux nazis sylvie tellier
qui va se faire à manger à direction
avec l'homme invisible
au mois de juin sous la selle ou bien
très bien qu'il relâche du muguet à
bulles et sylvie tellier qui prépare
l'aïd en suisse elodie gossuin qui boit
du vin dans des nounours et le guide de
soins qui est sur des rochers et le
gigot soins qui fait de la trottinette
voilà et le dernier allez on y va laury
thilleman c'est toi qui sont qu'une
façon pour cent ça nous fait des quatre
rigolote n'est ce pas tu peux pas me
mélanger tout les personnages étaient
bien sûr je serai plus quatre cartes
chaque y suit le premier il ya quatre
cartes identiques fait le signe qu'on
venu vous souvenez de votre signe oui
même si rihanna en sicile
mais retournons tourner tha carter il
faut redonner à les réaliser alésia les
i say party hockey l audi gosso dickens
rogers si tu n'as pas quand même si la 4
car si toi tu peux vous montrer deux cas
différents renault non non non non tu
t'es fan
américaine touchant non regardez là je
te montrer 2010 quand il ya deux qu'un
différentes
il n'a pas de sens et riche en enjeux
vous êtes fous ils jettent des changes
et les call centers
[Applaudissements]
triche on peut voir leur intensité des
changes
4 oui j'essaye de passer regarder
verrier vaincu leur choix
ces deux points ce qui vous fait un
score 2 4 non c'est ras le bol jimoh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avant ivan gym au sein des travaux le
questionnaire chrono savent attendus
sifflets je suis en train de faire
l'émission sérieux tu réponds photos
d'elle on est parti est ce qu'il y à là
le décodeur à part ça c'est quand même
pour les voleurs n'ont cessé les
questions alban côte entre toi j'ai des
questions sur toi mon frère et swaps sur
le coup ils ont eu dix sept bonnes
réponses on n'a jamais eu 17 bonne
réponse depuis qu'on est là jamais après
je dis qu'il est question de rapidité
c'est qu'on trouve attention top chrono
ça va dit mot pas trop speed race à
l'étoile dont ça fait quoi d'être une
star de cinéma maintenant ça va gémo
qu'est ce qui a changé dans la vie
depuis un an
le radical vaudois a tenu à commenter
ici
gimont qu'est-ce que tu n'as jamais eu
le temps de faire dans ta vie que tu
aimerais changé chez toi si c'était
possible
[Rires]
m
cette réponse réponse des trucages et
j'aimerais changer beaucoup de choses
c'est trop dur mais c'est quoi des gens
qui ont fait du cas chez eux alors
qu'elle est boulangerie par tout ce que
tu détestes 6 secondes et celle de
marquer des points très précis frère
qu'est ce qui te dégoûte peu plus dans
la vie maintenant
[Applaudissements]
yasi bonne réponse je vous en avais dit
c'est un point que jamais les riches ils
ont déjà réseau d'oussama ben non tout
ça ça va bien tout va bien le 2 ça va
maintenant il est temps de passer à la
troisième et dernière partie de stockem
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
signe que les gens pour voir maintenant
les signes secret que je leur est imposé
le style que je vais vous imposer c'est
simple il faudra que vous placiez pour
déclencher le kent moi j'y crois pas
trop à la chloroquine bon la troisième
partie il faut vous placiez faut que tu
dises à ton coéquipier ça doit crédit
crossfit games bassin comme ça je suis
les ai depuis le début de cette partie à
merde boulot
pourquoi parce que j'arrive pas à me
prendre toutes les cartes en même temps
je dis ça parce que tu perds ouais tu
perds pas en moins de deux non mais moi
j'ai beau match a juste envie de ne pas
être contents bien dans ce cas il faut
des clients leur carte à tout le monde
il faut détenir de cartes à toulouges à
pastor la tendance au moment de fatigue
et de soi qui va derrière
cette dernière partie va démarrer avec
six cartes et le premier qui me dit le
point commun prend un point on est parti
charlotte défier divorce et gluante ici
ouais pâtisserie je me sens ah ouais
[Applaudissements]
tout seul
l'accolade entre mes amis vous merci
infiniment
et moi je peux regarder ma tennis de
cartes via seulement parce qu'il est
rouge et à chacun le premier qui a
quatre cartes fait le signe à son
coéquipier est il aussi rappeler du
cygne du monde bien sûr à levante alcine
oui j'ai hâte alcine et si d'eric judor
vous avez le sinueux merci attention car
il a une passion c'est bon j'aimerais si
valence est apte à tout prix c'est qu'un
jour ça gêne pas parce que j'ai un peu
paniqué j'aille gimont j'aime ça veut
dire que tu es donne juste un peu
paniqué ça se voit que je faisais
[Applaudissements]
et albums quel était ton si ça se voit
que je fais du crossfit et quart pour
prendre un point merci aux gars des
monsieur madame 4/4 album est bel et
bien le kembs et jim hall a bien senti
ça nous fait donc un point mais qui
trois parties de gimeaux également on a
3 3 est ce qu'on va faire on va faire
une partie pourrait partager à deux pour
gagner trois juges apéro géant
allez c'est parti les pratiques
américaines allaient déjà remettez les
chalets les remettez les cartes bleues
est camille serre et tu pourras tu es
invité téléphone allez on est là bas
qu'est ce qu'il fait lui il fait ce
qu'il veut
fait ce qu'il veut non à nicosie vas-y
mon parti je jouais sagement jouer
sérieusement parce que là on n'est pas
là pour rigoler nous je crois que je
suis mieux construits
non
m
[Musique]
score final 2-1 des toits à trois points
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
désolé ça c'est votre place
bon on n'a plus besoin de vous
[Musique]
enfin le monde attendait tu vas avoir un
cadeau quand même ça c'est ma
bibliothèque et je te prends un dvd à
tulle ag für très nette
christophe nolan nous fait remonter le
temps avec le biopic de charles trenet
c'est bon eric il a eu son vieux dvd
vide en plus c'était juste pour la manne
accord car où vous allez pouvoir gagner
ceci voyage et vous êtes dans la rue il
ya une bagarre qui éclate une bagarre
mais nous voyons des comptes de quoi
compliquer plus trop de la gueule une
solution le poing américain pour
l'unique et sa gueule et lui l'abbé un
peu les doigts avant avoir un coup de
poing je veux le gagner celui-là baala
up
il est propre et après vous pouvez vous
battre
le cadeau est l'oeil les pauvres le
cadeau est pour vous mais moi si vous
tapiez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas si bons la grande finale va
remporter cette partie normalise été nul
je vais vous poser des questions à
chacun d'accord à tour de rôle y en a un
qui va aller là bas pour qu'il entende
pas les réponses de l'autre le premier
aura tout le temps pour répondre le
deuxième n'aura que 30 secondes 10
questions cette réponse identique vous
remportez le cadeau a remporté le grand
huit qui veut répondre tranquille qui
veut responsable de tout ça c'est quoi
ce matin moi je suis tranquille - mettez
à 15 km à l'est bien bien c'est bien
mais bon à la ok eric judor eric eric
eric les jeunes consomment ou voyelles
voyez réfléchir ce qui peut répondre
mais arrêtez je jouais avec la vanne de
consonnes ok ça marche
maitre gims ou maître yoda rap ou cinéma
je crois qu'il le connaît donc maître
yoda être yoda h la série ou z
le film avec yves montand h les
marseillais on n'embrasse pas gars ou le
reste du monde
je pense qu'il va dire le reste du monde
il essuya une table ou insuline défaite
essuyée une table table plutôt pour ou
une table plutôt pour vous à lui dire
qu'elle est bonne
j'ai choisi câblage aurait convaincu
table je suis convaincu plutôt pour ou
plutôt contre
mais il est positif djamel donc c'est
plutôt pour pour courant je pense
vraiment je serai la page car attention
[Applaudissements]
parce que vous visez je suis préfère te
faire griller par tes parents en train
de faire des bisous à ta copine ou
grilles étaient part en train de se
faire des bisous à toi qui te fait
griller ouais tu préfères te faire face
[Rires]
à la crise des années je préfère me
taire
rouler en trottinette électrique ou
manger un bol de vomi damien coin et qui
qui choisiraient bol de vomi par exemple
à ceux qui détestent les trottinettes
électriques à ce point alors un
trottinette électrique évidemment mma
vasys mma les mutuelles ou mma le léman
le sport est ensuite allemand ou du mot
c'est méchant françois c'est pas méchant
c'est dû nous en faut une vas-y prendre
celui qui a un chapeau almo à l'eau
[Applaudissements]
j'avais trente secondes pour répondre le
plus rapidement possible à ces questions
oui dix questions qui vous avez cet
incident thing pas très chaud j'avais
gagné le super cadeau américain brosse à
dents vous le donnerais on est parties
concernées voyelles et consonnes et
voyelles répondu peut-être ghimpu maître
yoda mrdja gims h la série z finch les
marseillais où le reste du monde du
monde essuyé une défaite essuyée une
table et ils tablent plutôt pour ou
plutôt content pour toujours positive et
recruteurs faire griller par terre
prévues partout par entretien des bisous
à ta meuf oublié tes parents en train de
faire des bisous grille était pas roulé
en trottinette ou électriques ou manger
un bol de venir de soupe est rôti france
je nous voyais pas vous qui triche n'est
pas une mort est là c'est parce que ce
cadeau en plus quel est l'intérêt trisha
nous n'avons que six bonnes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jamel debbouze
d'autres de venir jouer avec nous jamais
vraiment réussi alex il s'appelait
jamais on tourne actuellement c'est
cette commission qui ferait en sorte et
le diabète comedy club qui va bientôt
rouvrir autre chose c'est vrai que j'ai
triché
[Applaudissements]
les judas vérité juste venu pour faire
plaisir aux qu'eric alban ivanov pas al
banna encore par là et la même chose qui
avait pas de promo particulière on va le
voir au cinéma dans platoon tac tournée
avec éric soula projet taclant ce matin
qu'on va revoir et à bientôt 2021 avec
plaisir merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on d'amour
on attend tous de rejouer en attendant
mais notre énergie si j'ai vu premier
blackberry deuxième en pratique cela
rendez vous sur tel valoir jim o le plus
vite parce qu'elles soient les rendez
vous très vite sur une nouvelle partie
et d'ici à lectoure le quartier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]